good evening it's my pleasure just to
welcome you and say a few things about
the University lecture we're privileged
tonight to be able to hear George Lewis
the Columbia Edwin H case professor of
American music and the director of the
University Center for Jazz Studies
scholarship is a very lonely and
solitary Enterprise for many of us in
the university world and to have the
opportunity to share what we think about
in an environment where people take what
we say very very seriously and for us as
an audience to be able to hear what what
people have been thinking about is is
the highest form of intellectual
exchange that we can have at the
institution this particular institution
of the University lecture has been a
spectacular success over many many years
and those of us who have been able to
attend them through the past several
years have benefitted enormous Lee and
know that this really enriches the
tradition
George has this wonderful advantage
however of having something that we
really all care about and love to learn
about and listen to so it is a great
pleasure a special pleasure to have him
deliver at the University lecture this
evening now my pleasure to give you
Claude Steele the University Provost
Claude
Thank You Lee good evening everybody
it is a real pleasure to introduce the
faculty member who will give this year's
University lecture tonight professor
George Lewis the edwin case professor of
american music this is a proud and I'd
say particularly joyful tradition of
Columbia University as as Lee just noted
this lecture series is 40 years old over
the decades the lectures have provided
our community many nights of being
treated to the Distilled knowledge of
our most dedicated scholars sometimes in
a masterful overview of the whole
scholarly life sometimes in a lecture
about a single chapter in a long career
in important ways this type of exchange
is the thing that Columbia does best
tonight we are proud to be honoring
professor Lewis and we look forward to
with excitement to hear his remarks it
is customary to review professional
accomplishments of the person being
celebrated and I am NOT going to veer
from that tradition tonight but as I
mentioned them please note the sheer
variety of what he has applied himself
to and achieved over the course of his
career it is an impressive variety of
intellectual endeavors and and a very
high level of achievement in all of them
he is a composer and a performer with
more than 130 recordings to his credit
his early love and virtuoso mastery of
the trombone gave way to a more recent
embrace of the computer as his
instrument of choice his published
articles of commentary and criticism
extend beyond diverse musical subjects
to experimental video and visual art his
scholarship as was recognized in 2002
with a MacArthur Fellowship and the
quality of his teaching is recognized by
countless students past and present his
involvement with the Association for the
Advancement of creative music includes
joining the trail
organization as a nineteen-year-old and
then by turns helping to lead it
critique it and ultimately capture its
cultural and social significance through
an award-winning book published in 2008
called a power greater than itself the a
ACM and American experimental music he
just gave us a copy of this to which I'm
delighted to begin to look into
professor Lewis is a historian of
traditional music forms who now uses
software to compose and perform he has
been a faculty member at universities on
the west coast the East Coast and the
Midwest he has a degree from Yale and
happily for us as a faculty member at
Columbia later this year Oxford
University Press is scheduled to publish
the first of his two volume handbook of
improvisational studies how to account
for this journey of interest and output
and activity the answer must surely be
found in a spirit that is fully open to
new thinking contrary views and
unfamiliar experiences a spirit I would
add that rejects stereotypes and
preconceptions as a matter of course the
explanation for this variety of endeavor
comes from a willingness to be alive to
what is new it comes in a word from
improvisation professor Lewis's
interaction with colleagues and students
is defined by a desire on his part to
learn from each exchange in equal and
greater measure of than what he is able
to teach the this posture this
orientation toward learning and toward
creating new knowledge is the
indispensable ingredient in the quest to
continue one's education across the
entire arc of a lifetime and as a lesson
for all of us and now to talk about
improvisation as a way of life
reflections on human interaction the
Edwin case professor of American music
in Columbia's most recent university
lecturer George Lewis
oh well um thank you very much
Provost eel president Bollinger um
thanks so many of you distinguished
colleagues friends my wonderful and
creative wife Mia moussaka our
extraordinarily productive Department of
music a jewel of which the University as
a whole should be proud as our peers at
other institutions tell us Thank You
students friends for coming thank you
and this is going to be studied but
relatively brief remarks and I hope to
provide some small measure of recompense
for the honor you have all bestowed on
me by this evening the philosopher Jay
David Feldman likens humanity to an
improvisational theatre troupe that over
many years of performing together has
developed an extensive repertoire of
scenes that any member of the troupe can
initiate in the expectation of the
others will follow suit the totality of
the repertoire shared among us is what
might be called our way of life so what
do I mean by improvisation as a way of
life certainly because of musics
preeminence as the art that has provided
a wide variety of trenchant models and
experiences of how meaning is developed
and exchanged in real time one easily
conflates the notion of improvisation as
a way of life with a life in music and
indeed music was the starting point for
me a faithful companion to my Odyssey
from music pupil to jazz musician to
improviser to composer to
experimentalist to intermediate
technology artists to musicologist to
interdisciplinary scholar building a
life where all these elements and more
constitute not a linear trajectory but a
network whose nodes very dynamically
according to time
place and situation and along the way I
became part of a scholarly insurgency
working down and dirty in the trenches
to reassert the centrality of music
study to contemporary intellectual
discourse by using music itself to
analyze and even predict contemporary
cultural historical and social trends
this sort of thing Jacques Attali
attempted in his noise the political
economy of music as in the past we still
feel obliged today to draw a larger
lessons from music despite the ongoing
view of music and American public
intellectual life as a charming amused
bouche or to recall Dred Scott this
music tell us anything that we are bound
to respect
in response my friend and colleague the
musicologist jan paz ler proposes that
quote music can serve as a critical tool
activating and developing multiple
layers of awareness I invite the reader
to listen from music's resonance in the
world and through music to help us
imagine our future by writing through
this medium we can enrich our
understanding of musics capacity to
illuminate meaning itself well perhaps
my departmental colleagues will forgive
me for saying that this very tall order
may be a bit more than we musicologists
alone can handle and this is where I
depart from the common conflation of
improvisation as a way of life with a
life in music instead I'd like us to
consider peer are those understanding
that in philosophy we are not dealing
with the mere creation of a work of art
the goal is rather to transform
ourselves yes indeed this should this is
or should be the goal of our research of
the humanities and so it is with my work
on improvisation because in fact
improvisation is everywhere but it's
very hard to see because this ubiquitous
practice of everyday life fundamental to
the exist
and survival of every human formation is
as close to universal as contemporary
critical method could responsibly
entertain and thus I believe that the
humanistic and scientific study of
improvisation can provide us with new
understandings of the human condition as
I have found through my work with
Benjamin Pickett our former Columbia
musicology graduate student now at the
University of Southampton our two-volume
Oxford Handbook of critical
improvisation studies we are now able to
take advantage of a recent surge in
interdisciplinary critical inquiry on
improvisation across fields as diverse
as anthropology and sociology
organisational political cognitive and
computer science economics theology
neuroscience and psychology philosophy
linguistics cultural studies and
literary theory performance film gender
and sexuality studies architecture and
urban studies education and a lot of
other fields that I don't have time to
mention here and many of these fields in
fact have drawn heavily from
improvisation models of musical
organization thus the study of music
will be central to the development of an
exemplary literature of improvisation
studies perhaps I should begin at the
beginning what what is improvisation
well I do intend to discuss
improvisation nature its effects its
phenomenology but I must admit I'm not
really ready to provide a full
definition of it and I'm not going to
bore you with the Webster's this time
around I should warn you rather that's
simply touring the landscape of issues
that underlie this simple query is
already going to take up the rest of the
time we have this evening perhaps the
rest of my life then as a start my
evolving definition would first
incorporate both production and
perception second accept the importance
of both processes and
and third subsume both agency and
indeterminacy but before we go further I
want to reinterpret a rather misguided
witticism that often accompanies these
kinds of discussions especially from
those who imagine themselves able to
simply get cleverly minimize the
importance of this topic and to that end
well let us keep in mind for the outset
that erect the idea that a talk on
improvisation should itself be
improvised is rather like the insight
that a talk on primate physiology she
might truthfully be accompanied by
hooting however behind this
misapprehension lies the common-sense
notion that to understand improvisation
one should be able to improvise but what
exactly does an ability to improvise and
tail is improvisation the exclusive and
ineffable province of designated super
people with powers and abilities far
beyond those of mortal men
perhaps this trope is indispensable as I
well know to artists trying to win space
and in at least partially stochastic
process of art world success but what
I'm calling the fundamental condition of
improvisation obliges me to channel of
1976 discussion by Gilbert Ryle and he
said I shall soon be reminding you of
some of the familiar and unaddressed
sorts of improvisation which just qua
thinking beings we all si every day of
the week indeed in every hour of the
waking day even so to be sure not all of
our activities are improvised as a
student proposed in my recent graduate
seminar on this topic at the University
of Chicago co-taught with philosopher
arnold i davidson improvisation in a
strong sense the student wrote the
common sense notion of the practice
stands out as such against the
background of everyday life well from
the standpoint of the performing arts
this could indeed be the case but the
line between improvised and non
improvised activities may not be as
as we suppose philosopher Bruce Alice
Benson identifies the improvisation
moment within the nominally non
improvised activity of music composition
so as an opening thought experiment let
us consider the possibility that it is
the non improvised event that stands out
against the background of everyday life
and often demands to I want now to go
further and to show that to be thinking
what he is here and now up against he
must both be trying to adjust himself to
just this present once only situation
and in doing this to be applying lessons
already learned there must be in his
response the union of some ad-hoc Larry
with some know-how if the normal human
is not at once improvising and
improvising warily he is not engaging
his somewhat trained wits in some moment
relate live issue to perhaps acting from
sheer unthinking habit so thinking I now
declare quite generally is at the least
the engaging of partly trained wits in a
partly fresh situation it is the pitting
of an acquired competence or skill
against a none programmed opportunity
obstacle or hazard it is a bit like
putting some new wine into old bottles
supposing it were possible John Stuart
Mill Road in 1869 to get houses built
corn grown battles fought causes causes
tried and even churches erected in
prayer said by machinery by automatons
in human form
even at this point in the 19th century
images of automata turn up quite often
and programmable musical automata
automata were known at least since the
automatic flute player that you see here
which was described in the ninth century
by the brothers Musa and Baghdad based
on a Greek design from the 3rd century
BC an important part of my work in
improvisation today is rooted in
practices that arose in the computer
music communities beginning in the early
1970s when composers use the new mini
and micro computers to produce
interactive
or computer-driven works well before the
better-known new media interactivity
that began in the late 1980s composer
joel chata be who we see on the bottom
right one of the earliest pioneers call
these machines interactive composing
instruments that made musical decisions
as they responded to a performer
introducing the concept of shared
symbiotic control of a musical process
and now the most advanced of these
musical works what I've come to call
creative machines make music in real
time
when I the improviser come to terms with
an engage with another improviser I come
to terms with the others temporality
part of our conferring particularity on
each other is the conferring of time I
give time to the other such that the
other person's distinctive temporality
is allowed to engage with mine and
vice-versa to mutual benefit we could
compare that voice over that remark from
the theologian Jeremy Begbie with the
phenomenology of Halford shoots from
1964 on making music together which he
sees as quote a social relationship
founded upon the partaking in common of
different dimensions of time
simultaneously lived through by the
participants for Arnold Davidson
collective intelligibility unfolds in
real time when the participants in
social interaction are committed to
making sense of and giving sense to
themselves and others so for me in this
regard
creative machines that take part in
collective musical improvisation zazz
thesaurus are just now exemplified the
radical position of anthropologists of
Technology Lucy Suchman that is I take
the boundary between persons and
machines to be discursively and
materially enacted rather than naturally
affected and to be available for
refiguring the Center for jazz studies
here at Columbia sponsors a jazz seminar
group here where scholars students and
artists come together at least twice
yearly to consider the impact of jazz on
American culture and increasingly its
international impact as well at one
study group session a while ago
professor Robert Amelie the center's
founder suggested a conference
addressing Hurricane Katrina which had
just devastated much of New Orleans
I don't remember precisely what
Professor emelius said that day but one
came away with the understanding that he
felt that jazz could be central to
rebuilding New Orleans hmm jazz would
rebuild the city what
that means when music exercises such
small impact on our public intellectual
and political culture it seemed evident
to me that the element of jazz that
could most transiently be deployed as an
agent of change was its underlying
lifeblood practice of improvisation
while in public discourse improvisation
is most commonly provoked in a
pejorative or negative sense as in
improvised foreign policy or military
improvisation in Afghanistan part of the
poverty of response of our government to
Katrina lay in its refusal or inability
to improvise concerning the agency of
objects bruno latour reminds us that
those who watch the Columbia shuttle
instantly transform for the most
complicated human instrument ever
assembled to a rain of debris falling
over Texas will realize how quickly
objects flip-flop their modes of
existence so it was with the levees and
engineers and organizational theorists
such as David Mann Danka
James Kendra Trisha Watson Dorf have
developed both cognitive models and
improvising computer programs that
respond to simulated emergency emergency
situations showing how an orientation to
improvisation could be key to developing
new ways to analyze emergency situations
respond to conditions and develop
flexible in mobile situations and
solutions under intense time pressure
John Cage compared indeterminate
performance to the work of quote a
traveler who must constantly be catching
trains the departures of which have not
been announced but which are in the
process of being announced he must
continually be ready to go alert to the
situation and responsible similarly and
perhaps in a more urgent register dance
historian Daniel Goldman finds parallels
between contact improvisation and the
techniques of falling and slack
musculature that 1960s Freedom Riders
trained themselves in becoming what
Goldman called quote creative
improvisers putting their bodies on the
line
in Goldman's account as one freedom
writer described an attempt to support
the Freedom Rides at a Mississippi Jail
in it was a heroic effort at
organization improvise under the most
difficult conditions again we turn to
John Stuart Mill the human faculties of
perception judgment discriminated
feeling mental activity and even moral
preference are exercised only in making
a choice perhaps so but Columbia's own
professor Sheena Iyengar in her new book
the art of choosing contrasts Mills
brand of individualism with equally rich
tradition of societal collectivism
interestingly the 1960s emergence of
collective musical free improvisation in
Europe in the United States began to
challenge first the individual isms of
bebop and then the primacy of the lone
composer as the supreme icon of Western
art music Nicole dree maintains for
example that British free improvisation
from this period forward is marked by
quote a dismissal of empty individualism
and appreciation of the values of
collective discovery as called RIA notes
there was an absence of prior
instructions ie
chord changes pre-established forums etc
and that absence was essential to the
success of the undertaking negotiations
without preconditions
so to speak the sound of improvised
music is the sound of negotiation
through sonic communication proposals
are made debated rejected and accepted
power dynamics pursued and for brief
moments consensus achieved until the
debate begins anew
guitarist Derek Bailey one of the
earliest and most celebrated this
generation of British free musicians
whose suspicions of academia seems
ironic since his book on improvisation
is perhaps the most widely cited in the
academic literature declared that free
improvisation in addition to being a
highly skilled musical craft is open to
use by almost anybody beginners children
and non musicians perhaps the type of
person offended by the thought that
anyone can do it we'll find some
reassurance and learning that Albert
Einstein looked upon improvisation as an
emotional and intellectual necessity
well okay I'm stuck but if anyone can do
it and anything is possible then how can
we possibly judge outcomes mistake is
missing the chance a chance to do
something I mean sometimes you can't
decide let's go maybe sometimes better
x-coordinate will do log but using the
chance is basic idea about making a
mistake
music sometimes ask strange
so a mistake is missing the chance
missing the opportunity
why because improvisation involves not
only outwardly expressive action but
inwardly manifested attention and the
analysis of conditions we must choose
where to direct our awareness and the
consequences of those choices feedback
into the next expressive action as well
as the next moment of attending thus we
can understand the experience of
listening or attending as an
improvisation Act engaged in by everyone
and / an a practice of active engagement
with the world and in that way perhaps a
good improviser consistently makes good
use of the conditions he or she finds or
as the old Ward Heeler George Washington
Plunkett of Tammany Hall put it I see my
opportunities and I took them but
finding opportunities in relationships
there's only one way to go the
philosopher and musician David
Rothenberg tells us to look for
connections among themes so seemingly in
Congress that at first contact they seem
to make no sense
accidental meaning is essential for
improvisation because we are never fully
in control seeing the world as a
confluence of sudden happenings where
the order we discover emerges as the
result of chance or drawing upon my own
experience with computers since about
nineteen seventy seven or so part of the
analytic task facing any improviser
whether or not the improviser as a
computer involves discovering or even
positing ways in which seemingly
unrelated material can become part of
either an existing or a new structure
within the emergent music Arnold
Davidson compares this account with
primo Levy's identification in a very
specific context of that form of
intelligence that consists of quote
finding or creating relationships
between apparently unrelated orders of
event
for Davidson once again I'm collective
intelligibility des unfolds in real time
when the participants are committed to
making sense of a giving sense to
themselves and others the inner life of
choice is difficult to conceive even the
loquacious ly insightful John Cage found
it Rocky going loath to mention the word
improvisation in any sense with a
pejorative the composers early writings
instead described processes of
indeterminate performance that
essentially amounted to the same thing
for many of us filling in color we're
outlines are given or feeling his way
Cage evokes mysticisms automatisms
dreams random number tables ancient
divination methods such as the II Ching
and other removals of direct agency
which he saw as undesirable intrusions
of taste and psychology as a means by
which one can identify with no matter
what eventualities which is part of what
improvisers must do in 2008 Erin
Berkowitz and his associates at Harvard
observed that particular regions of the
brain were highly active during simple
tasks requiring keyboard improvisation
but relatively dormant during
performances of memorized scales and
keyboard pieces these brain areas
included the anterior cingulate cortex
ACC already shown to be involved in
cognitive tasks including decision
making voluntary selection and willed
action from a neurobiological
perspective the authors of the study
maintained our experiment reveals that
improvisation involves regions of the
brain that subserve the generation and
comprehension of sequences making a
decision among competing possible
sequences to perform and the creation of
a plan for the motor execution of the
decided upon sequence or once again as
mill maintained he who chooses his plan
for himself employs all his faculties he
must use observation to see reasoning
and judgment to foresee
activity to gather materials for
decision discrimination to decide and
when he has decided firmness and
self-control to hold on to his
deliberate decision for Iyengar true
choice requires that a person have the
ability to choose an option and not be
prevented from choosing it by any
external voice external force but indeed
the discourse of rules ie constraints is
never far from a discussion of
improvisation and iearned our
conversation with the famous jazz
trumpeter Wynton Marsalis covered
familiar ground in its discussion you
have to have some restrictions in jazz
Marsalis said anyone can improvise with
no restrictions but that's not jazz jazz
always has some restrictions otherwise
it might sound like noise we can
juxtapose the Marsalis understanding
with John Cruz as a pound of sound under
slavery quote prior to the mid 19th
century black music appears to been
heard by captors and overseers primarily
as noise that is that strange
unfathomable and incomprehensible Cruz
further notes that hearing black music
is noise continued well into the 19th
century and arguably much longer even to
the present so it was with the early
reception of jazz the fact that this
discussion seems benignly neglect moving
to more recent times Cru Cruz observes
that quote criticism of black music is
falling beyond the bounds of
respectability continues like clockwork
and can be found applied to every genre
and style shift in the history of black
music from early blues to jazz up to rap
and hip hop the negative reaction to
black music occurs most consistently
when moral gatekeepers hear noise and
their younger Ward's especially youth
hear music
but as cruise points out for slave
owners to hear only noise is to remain
removed from how slave soundings probe
their circumstances and cultivated
histories and memories even though the
enterprise of music-making was
continually made fragile by the
ever-present threat of social
dislocation and violence and on this
point I think I would go a little
further than Cruz in fact for slave
owners to hear only noise is actually to
propose the erasure of those histories
and memories and in fact this is what
the historical record reveals of course
the concept of noise cannot be contained
within the domain of a prescriptive
aesthetics as Cruz points out noise is
sound out of order it evades alludes
spills out flows over the preferred
channels out of place resistant to
capture a din that prevents the powerful
from perceiving the collective symbolic
Enterprise of the dominated inspired by
Tunisia is revolt
earlier this month which out stood
President Ben Ali
here many Egyptians face many of the
same issues
Noyes introduces uncertainty and thus
appears whatever changes in the offing
authoritarian regimes provide particular
interpretations of normative categories
but when we want change we bring the
noise in Egypt Wisconsin Tunisia Libya
or elsewhere as Jacques Attali put it
any noise when two people decide to
invest their imaginary and their desire
in it becomes a potential relationship
of future order so our constraints
really something we need to improvise or
is there a deeply rooted fear that
improvisation like noise like slaves or
subjects of authoritarian regimes can
simply get out of hand and run buck wild
perhaps recognizing constraints as part
of the improvisation process of analysis
of conditions but can we really even
know all the constraints under which we
are operating at any given moment as
Michel Foucault put it to avoid quote
letting ourselves be determined by more
general structures of which we may well
not be conscious or which we may have no
control we must transform the critique
conducted in the form of necessary
limitation into a practical critique
that takes the form of possible crossing
over and pressing over this is where I
sort of disagree with the translation
the the crack determines translated the
term from small as translated as
crossing over and I interpret that more
I interpret that Morris and loudness
permission permission to exceed the
necessary limitations the ability to
improvise Marsalis told Iyengar comes
from fundamental knowledge and this
knowledge limits the choices you can
make and will make knowledge is
important where there's a choice well I
want to suggest a contrary view here
I've already implied that improvisation
is more a matter of necessity than
ability but I want to go further and
suggesting that knowledge and powers and
expands choice rather than limiting it
as John Coltrane put it was it Julia
Child I'm the more you know the more you
can create
so we can view choice as a set of
received options or as an
epistemological side of investigation we
can consider knowledge not as a
background for intention less regulated
improvisation after the Hobby Tourism
Board year but as the desired output of
an improvisation Act bound up with
epistemological project that nurtures
the possibility of change we're framed
improvisation as involving attention
analysis choice and response and here as
jeremy Begbie notes we do not need to
endorse the inflated claim sometimes
made about group improvisation to see
that there are patterns of action ways
of being and behavior here which would
seem at the very least to illuminate the
character of authentic human freedom for
Begbie quote a properly theological
account of freedom sees it as mediated
by and through the other in a process of
concentrated dialogical action where the
constraint of others is experienced not
as essentially oppressive but as
conferring and confirming an inalienable
particularity and uniqueness well but at
this point I think it's time to talk
about not about freedom and because
versus constraint but freedom in the
face of power theorizing creative
machines brings up the question of the
relationship between the concept of
improvisation the notion of interaction
interactivity can be purely reactive a
sensor base door opener a car alarm or
even the kinds of sensorial active
spaces created by new media artists
using video infrared radio frequency
fields or other technologies here I want
to venture that interaction becomes
improvisation when a third term freedom
enters the picture when an interactive
analysis concludes that a response is
demanded to a situation or an action
that could not be wholly for seeing an
oncoming train or car a threatening
animal that is free with respect to the
attractors position ethically as Begbie
tells us quoting Alistair McFadden to
recognize and intend the freedom of the
other in response is to recognize that
the form and content of that response
cannot be overturned by the address
there is a readiness to allow the cause
of others to transform us transform us
in response
well if as I am suggesting and
performances of improvised music the
possibility of internalizing alternative
value systems is implicit from the start
I think we can propose now not am NOT a
metaphysics of machine consciousness but
a phenomenology of freedom as dialogic
interaction in which we can be ready to
allow a creative machine that is
perceived by us as acting in a free way
during the performance to influence and
even transform us not a stimulus
response but it's subject to quasi
subject it suffice us for the
interaction that the device is free with
respect to us and that it's action is
not one that we can foresee or control
but perhaps one that we can it we
perceive that we can influence through
dialogue as if it were a free being like
us and it simply acts or in this case
sounds in a way that demands a response
and return this may have fair circular
in fact what my responses that is in
fact recursive that is the practice of
freedom draws its power from freedom
itself
I don't want to claim improvisation as
an ideal Democratic utopia after all
both Stephen Greenblatt and sweatin
Todorov view a European talent for
opportunistic improvisation is vital to
the Spanish conquest of the new world
nor do I claim that improvisation simply
produces freedom architect Tom Martin
and musician Christopher Dell in their
book on improvisation urban studies
point out a problem with this assumption
improvisation is often experience
experiences something forced rather than
as a mask rhetoric and is also connoted
that way well we had to improvise what
people say in the hope that soon the
situation will be established where
order of rules again what this means is
once again we must make common cause
with Foucault and observing that where
there is talk of freedom we must speak
of power which for Foucault is quote
exercised only over free subjects by
this we mean individual or collective
subjects who are faced with a field of
possibilities in which several kinds of
conduct several ways of reacting in
modes of behavior are available in other
words only free subjects are capable of
choice and therefore only free subjects
can have the ability to improvise but
also in the free subjects possibility of
improvisation must be grounded in the
possibility of resistance quote at the
very heart of the power relationship and
constantly provoking it are the
recalcitrance of the will and the
intransigence of freedom
indeed improvisation here for me becomes
not so much a practice as an aspiration
toward freedom that even as it is doomed
to failure nonetheless produces a
consciousness that continuously
transgresses limits and resist their
imposition the ideal here as Vadim er
Jankovic understands is a mlange
division lost at the soup last acrobatic
a kind of mobility of identity or what
the first century Roman rhetorician
quintillion famed for her discussions of
improvisation called mobili Toscanini
mobility haces mobility in constancy
changeable Mnet's of the mind and of the
soul a dangerous hybrid formed by
agency and indeterminacy whose ultimate
outcome is a continuous transformation
of both other and self so perhaps the
nineteen sixties musicians were right to
call their work free improvisation where
the primary work was as much critical
and political as aesthetic and sonic how
is freedom achieved practiced maintained
in the face of power whatever may be the
responses to those questions the ACM
understanding has always been that
genius can only breathe in an atmosphere
of freedom and mobility mobility indeed
is a trope most centrally represented by
the defining moment in the origins of
jazz namely that after 300 years of very
real silence of violence and mobility
and terror rather than say of freely
chosen conceptual silence of four
minutes or so one can well imagine the
newly freed slaves developing a post
slavery participation performance form
in which each person is encouraged to
speak and move their bodies here
mobility means Chains and the expression
of freedom is corporally as well as
discursively asserted as with the great
migration of african-americans in the
early mid to 20th century as Farah
Jasmine Griffin our own Farah Desmond
Griffin put it in her hermeneutics of
the migration quote for the
african-american migrant protagonists a
shift in the way power is exercised is
spatial not temporal however as yields
Duluth wrote quote it is a vital concern
of every state not only to vanish
nomadism but to control migrations and
more generally to establish a zone of
rights over an entire exterior if it can
help it the state does not disassociate
itself from a process of capture of
flows of all kinds populations
commodities or Commerce money capital
etc but when that control breaks down as
in Egypt Tunisia or Wisconsin we find
the nomads taking on the condition of
improvisation in the form of what move
over today brooms speaking of
improvisation on this very stage in 2007
called quote a human response to
necessity
composer that improvised the speaker
structure usually see it as something
created in advance and articulated in
performance for linguists Michael
silverstein however a convert a
conversation amounts to quote an
improvisational performance of culture
in which an interactive text is a
structure in real time of organized
segmental and recognizable event units
of the order of social organizational
regularity social event in real time has
a social action and event real time has
the capacity to be causally effective in
the universe of identities as a basis
for relationships and further social
action or as psychologists are keith
Sario tells us an improvised scene is
emergent moreover as David Rothenberg
puts it when I say the world is
improvising that doesn't mean I listen
and hear no plan no order what I mean is
there's no easy way to reckon a
structure a beginning middle and end and
here we can take as one example the
world wide web perhaps the largest
collective improvisation ever created
we're individual actions of navigation
and choice improvised in dialogue with
local and global conditions both within
and outside the network results in
shifting allegiances that are inevitably
transforming histories and cultural
memories and we're vast asymmetries and
agendas corporate collective individual
cultural viewpoints and infrastructure
becomes subject to a summing of agencies
mark Hanson and Ben Rubens important
installation listening post from 2002
exemplifies an artistic form the
possibilities of these this new way of
thinking about improvisation I am fully
awake sir
mine in Pennsylvania
I'm comfortable with my assertions my
Manny's decided I'm the whitelighter
I am stumpy I am an artist
I am a professional killer dear I'm
bored
I am NOT repeating I am a student here
I'm still used to windows
I am from Argentina
I am proud of not being British of
course the universe of identities
includes race gender sexuality national
origin and other markers and we inquire
further into the construction process
itself we find the notion of
performativity superseded by a more
descriptive concept or what Ben Pickett
calls improvisation t after all these
unscripted performances of identity take
place in real time and recalling
velopment they draw from quote an
extensive repertoire of scenes that any
member of the troupe can initiate in the
expectation that others will follow suit
I'm a traveler and this is the last I
thread myself and my instrument between
groups of passengers all the way to a
seat in the last row of a crowded
airplane a balding fellow with a gin and
tonic on his food tray stairs with
furtive curiosity
first at me then at my saxophone face so
we're going to have some entertainment
of this flight huh well there's a movie
I think no it would be great to have
some live entertainment right here on
the airplane short pause in the
engagement with the universe of chance
this chance have all the power not if
we're ready in the thought of young
Kelly which we find a frank even near
romantic engagement improvisation and
exception to the remarkable perhaps if
in deformational silence of philosophers
of music regarding one of music's
primary constitutive practices as that
Kelvin said the in improvisation the two
provident man wants to reclaim the
innocence of day-to-day life and to
resolve on the wing the small problems
born of the indeterminate moment he thus
disturbs his own adaptation to accident
and deprives himself of the time that
ensured his safety
now what Yankovic is offering here is
not a defense of a cautious refusal to
engage situations in real time rather
one can be too Provident to experience
the fullness of life and here he makes
common cause with Michel Foucault as for
those for whom to take pains to begin
and begin again to try to make mistakes
to start all over from top to bottom and
to still find a way to falter or step by
step as for those for whom in short to
work while holding oneself in reserve
and restlessness is equivalent to
abdication well we're obviously not from
the same planet thank you
well first I want to thank George for
that illuminating lecture that puts all
of our lives in a different life
different light full of more
possibilities I think and I just want to
say we do have a few minutes I think for
questions so if people would like to ask
questions there are two microphones in
the in the aisles there and so people
could come forward and do that there we
have do you have any comments on the
difference between a solo improv versus
improvisation among a large group or an
infinitely large group with respect to
those constraints well there are a lot
of ways to talk about that musically but
I think I'm going to leave music behind
for a moment if you think about it we do
this all the time is it making I guess
what you're calling improv and I wasn't
sure whether you met the actual improv
or musical improv or some sort of
performance art piece or maybe behavior
in lines or trying to you know to one of
my favorite experiences of solo versus
group in Provence group improvisation is
burbling to the front of I've learned
this I learned this finally by living in
Holland for a while people don't wait in
lines what happens is you have to verbal
to the front you have to find your way
there and if you can stay in the back
forever if you follow the British or
American way of doing things so you're
learning new techniques new ways of
behaving in group situations and so for
the soloist of course one's primary
audience is oneself but also one is at
all times engaged with history with
memory with who you are your identity
your attempts to project definitions of
the situation into an environment that
which you may be the only audience
so I guess that's how I would think
about this the more I come to this
realization the more I see that term
improvisation and music it becomes only
one domain and we can learn quite a bit
by considering the rest of our social
lives as improving improvisation is
involving improvisation and that might
end up improving how we think about
human communication within the musical
domain
you can ask even improvised questions if
you'd like to I'm trying to find the
best way to ask this um but um that
quote from my thinking of Salix and
Yvonne slipping back yes is it where he
said mistake was missing the chance this
is her patient Kevin Parker's remark
exactly um one of the many options of
making choices of interaction is not
responding and I'm guessing that's what
we call laying out but if you don't
respond isn't that missing the chance
and isn't that like one clear
restriction that could risk interaction
I think Alex said it was hard to hear
that remark I tried to clean it up the
audio but I wasn't successful he said
sometimes it's better to do nothing and
of course doing nothing in an
environment is a kind of response in the
end so simply in I guess they were
talking in the musical domain simply
making a sound is not the only mode of
response if we're thinking about it
again for a neurobiological perspective
the moment you heard the sound the brain
already responded and so we're already
in a position where we're responding to
things and the choice of actually
placing something back into the space
allows us the opportunity to even while
making the response to realize that you
miss the opportunity to do nothing
okay how do you understand the role of a
university and promoting the idea of
improvisation as necessary or important
across several different fields
what's it I think that for me I realized
it took a while for me to figure out how
to the relation between the lever and
the place to stand in terms of the
University I guess I came to the
University from the performative world
and the most frequently asked question
among my some of the some of my
performance buddies was well can you go
and do gigs whenever you want and I
thought well I could do that I guess but
this is a first of all this is a gig
right here and secondly it's a it's a
gig with an enormous brain trust of very
interesting people some of whom were
also fantastic musicians so it was an
opportunity to learn from them now that
now to get more directly into your
question it seems to me that
improvisation as I've outlined it is a
field is an interdisciplinary field so
that each of the fields I outline would
have its own way to study improvisation
so that it wouldn't be limited to the
music department or something and so my
my dream about the Hawks the Oxford
Handbook is that some enterprising
graduate student abd or postdoctoral
student can love these two giant volumes
into the into the room and plop it on
the desk of the chair of the department
and say you see improvisation really is
a field and so I guess that's one of the
things I felt that being part of the
university allows me to do is to take
advantage of that extraordinary of grain
trust I mean that's the people in this
room
around I mean incredible people here and
I can't hope to really match some of
their achievements and so I'm just
trying to make that little make of space
as you would do in a province with
musicians what you try to do is you make
a space for other people to be free and
create the a sim model if you will of
atmosphere that's why I think the
university could do thank you yes is
improvisation exclusively human well I
just spent all that time talking about
machines so I guess not know is that
that I'm thinking about how far back you
go I think in terms of evolution and the
possibility that added innovation maybe
may be part of the part of evolution
this may be a very very early form of
adaptation well it's interesting
one can um take this metaphor and very
exciting directions
I don't not being a biology person I
don't feel comfortable doing that but I
could say that I have run across the odd
paper talking about the role of
improvisation in genetics so that I
wasn't really able to to evaluate those
papers and that's why I'm hoping to be
part of an interdisciplinary team of
people who could yeah how different is
improvisation from kind of an intuitive
expertise that's built up over time
that's just you know unleashed when
there's a decision to make or in the
case we talked about before a decision
not to make you know it's funny I didn't
mention the word intuition it's part of
the reason for me is that I'm funny
intuition to be one of those concepts
where the goalposts constantly move and
I think there's been for me a kind of
misuse of the term - in other words to
close off further study in other words
at anytime we want to we can say oh it's
intuitive and
that can't be questioned it's your
intuition and your intuition is what it
is so I keep thinking this let's push
let's peel let's peel away some of those
layers of intuition let's find out
underneath let's find out what's
underneath so I'm not posing any
opposition at all between improvisation
and intuition in fact but I do think
that more a bit more study is needed in
both areas to be able to say more with a
more grounded way about intuition and
creativity by the way so improvisation
and freedom it's a issue that you dealt
with and as I was listening to you I was
both listening to what you were saying
and I was listening to you as well and I
called the university lecture concerto
how do we speak as well as what you were
saying and something I would propose in
the consideration of freedom is
quotation I noticed how often you quoted
how you quoted people who were quoting
other people how you quoted and refused
to translate for instance quintillion
how you quoted and retranslated I was
disappointed never to hear you misquote
which in a way is central to
improvisation but both quotation and
miss rotation and I have to say in
academia we have a academia seen as a as
a place of improvisation or if not
improvisation or counter improvisation
there is a militancy a militating
against miss quotation however my
experience as an editor the only person
I ever edited who did not misquote was
Stanley fish it's a very rare quality in
fact in academia not to miss but to
perhaps you'll wish to be improvisers
but improvisation in quotation well it's
interesting you know I mean there's the
old Harold Bloom
the poetic misprision and you know while
I did misquote I did take some liberties
with quotations I'll put it that way
um you know in the interest of time I
would sort of say that um I guess one
could say that come that's in the
musical domain for example I often heard
people say things like well we wanted to
play bebop but we couldn't quite get it
right so we ended up doing something
different and that a form of misquoting
of this oppression that leads to new
possibilities and probably I didn't
misquote because you know there are a
lot of people here who would know it and
they might be upset and I don't happen
to be in the cuz they're saying position
that Stanley fish is perhaps one day yes
because one more question I'm just
curious to know what your how how you
view the future of improvisation do you
see it as a an increased refinement
towards greater and greater structure or
do you see it as a move towards just
deconstruction and increasing chaos well
you know I guess for me I spent a lot of
time exploding that manichaean ideology
of structure versus freedom and the
worldwide web reference is my way of
doing that it seems to me that an
emergent structure that's constantly
shifting and that no one person has
control over seems to be you know as
they used to say the Internet at least
until the days of Comcast was you know
no one controlled it and so it seems to
me that that I'm thinking of that as a
model for the present and the future of
improvisation in some ways improvisation
will remain static on one
that is to say as a fundamental human
activity as a fundamental birthright I
don't see it tending toward I mean one
could certainly use it to decide to well
we're going to improvise and
progressively come up with something
that then we can say this is structured
however that ignores the fact that the
improvisation itself also has structure
so but it may be a structure that
emerges and maybe a structure that you
have to capture in real time to jump to
study rather than something that you can
impose and once it's dead you can then
say we have it so the big promise is to
be in Matias Reyes when we talk about
these kinds of things that's the biggest
issue I think and that's going to be
part of the working method part of the
graphic part historical so I'd like to
take this opportunity to again thank
George Lewis for a wonderful evening and
a wonderful talk and then I'd like to
also invite everyone to join us in a
reception in the room right behind this
stage where you can have Adam again with
regard to questions and ideas you may
have so so please let's give George
another thanks